this is a show play a little bit of the
of the preview for you
so terminal list has a 39 this show's
gonna be we already know that this is a
100
rave review before it even comes out we
don't even it doesn't need to come out
no one needs to see it
this is critically acclaimed already
from the beginning but here's the
preview
okay here we go
[Music]
we're hitting the road to shine a light
on women who inspire us to be bolder and
braver leadership doesn't look one way
it's a giant rainbow you're not gonna
break me down you'll get worn out before
i do women who push us outside our
comfort zone you got this and make us
laugh i'm in deep georgia and they might
have never met a muslim or they don't
know they have or they don't know they
have because we walk among you
do you have a marriage that has been on
public display since the beginning you
said the gutsies thing you ever did was
stay in your marriage that doesn't mean
that's right for everybody
to throw someone's life away when people
really do make changes i just believe in
second chances my mother needed
rehabilitation not prison your survival
is your power
someone say to me you're not good enough
because you have melanin how dare you i
have a masters in whites i just want
places to get a ged in blacks
[Music]
every single person makes some impact on
the planet every single day
[Music]
we can choose what sort of difference we
make
speak truth to power
you know there's a movie called
misery stephen king movie came out
you know years ago
with kathy bates
and she plays this insane sociopath who
takes this guy prisoner and at one point
she puts a a two by four between his
legs at the ankles and then takes a
sledgehammer and um
and hammers his feet so that they're
pointing at each other diagonally like
hobbling him so he can't go anywhere
and i bring that up because hillary
clinton reminds me a lot of kathy bates
in that film but also because i'd rather
have that happen to me
then watch one episode of that show
um
i don't want to see it is what i'm
trying to say it looks terrible
and it's not only a terrible show
but it continues to
cheapen the idea of courage which is
maybe the worst thing about because the
show is called the gutsy
and then it's called gutsy we've got
hillary clinton
kim kardashian meegan the stallion
few of these women have ever displayed
courage in their lives least about
hillary clinton
well today's world is a scary one too
many people don't seem to care about the
truth moral standards have flown out the
window and i'd argue that's all rooted
in people becoming less religious that's
why it's more important than ever that
we take a step back from all this
craziness and keep our relationship with
god strong the best way to do that is by
praying every day with hallow hallow is
the number one christian prayer wrap in
the u.s it's like calm or head space but
rooted in catholic faith as opposed to
the religion of leftism hallo offers
over 000 audio guided prayers
meditations and christian music tracks
some of those popular prayers include
the bible and a year with father mike
schmitz prayers led by uh mark wahlberg
mario lopez jim kavisel
kids prayers and meditations and much
more than that hallow helps me find
peace and calm throughout the day it
helps me sleep better as well lower my
anxiety levels and teach my kids not to
be terrible humans which is also an
important detail here so let hallow help
you find your peace and strength
throughout the day go to hallow.com matt
walsh or text pray to
1-855-944-5684 and get an extended
three-month free trial during which
you'll have access to all 5000 plus
meditations in paris that's hallow.com
matt walsh or text pray to
1-855-944-5684
for three months free reclaim your piece
in this crazy world download hallo today
um and then and then we're told in the
film the gutsiest moment of her life was
when she chose to stay with bill clinton
presumably after the lewinsky affair
but she also stayed with him after he
raped juarita broderick
allegedly
um and when he was accused of sexual
assault and harassment many other times
and when he was jet-setting with jeffrey
epstein hanging out on sex slave island
she stayed through all of that didn't
just stay but she actually slandered and
silenced and intimidated
her
rapist husband's accusers
and then had jeffrey epstein murdered
allegedly
so is that courage i mean is that what
that is
or is that being a heartless soulless
power-hungry
demonic old witch
[Music]
i mean tomato tomato i suppose
well before you go uh hit the subscribe
button and ring the bell and while
you're at it if you want to go watch or
listen to my full show head to
dailywire.com and subscribe you can also
catch my show on spotify apple podcast
or wherever you get your podcast so go
check it out now i demand it
your compliance is somewhat appreciated